hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es eine
schicht dessert und zwar eins was super
schnell geht und einfach ist und perfekt
wenn sich mal besuch ankündigt ich hab
das jetzt mit weintrauben gemacht ist
gehen natürlich auch alle anderen
früchte und die krähen ist super lecker
besteht aus quark aus sahne superlecker
trotzig vielleicht einfach mal an die
zeit hier zuallererst die zutaten
wir benötigen weintrauben oder angriff
früchte eurer wahl
außerdem magerquark kalte schlagsahne
mascarpone von den extrakt eine bio
zitrone etwas puderzucker dann benötigen
wir entweder schoko cookies diesem
selbst gekauft nicht selbst gebacken
oder wenn ihr möchtet amaranth schoko
müsli zu den cookies nochmal zum
schichten benötigt die irgendwas süßes
und crunchy ist entweder nimmt ihr
wirklich diese selbst gekauften cookies
oder vielleicht habt ihr ja nur selbst
gebackene cookies da das ist so eine art
resteverwertung das gleiche gilt auch
für kuchenteig oder irgendwas was hier
noch da habt aber ich habe für mich
entdeckt dieser schoko amaranth ist der
schnitt unglaublich lecker zusammen mit
dem wein traum und mit der creme und mit
der creme machen wir es auch weiter ich
hab mir meine küchenmaschine könnte aber
auch selbstverständlich ein
handrührgerät verwenden
und dann gebe ich jetzt zuallererst
mascarpone und quark rein und dann kommt
ein anderen zutaten noch mit dazu
[Musik]
ich tue bringt es immer erst die festen
zutaten rein also mascarpone und quark
und dann erst die sahne bei mir schon
ganz oft passiert dass dann plötzlich
einmal so gespritzt ist und da war mein
oberteil versauert teilweise die wand
und alles was hier darum herum lag war
super ärgerlich
[Musik]
bei der bio zitrone bitte unbedingt
darauf achten dass ihr wirklich nur die
schale abtreibt und nicht das weiß er
denn das wasser schmeckt total bitter
und falls sie keine bio zitrone das gilt
zum beispiel auch eine bio limette oder
zitronenaroma aber ich finde das passt
super gut mit dem vanille zusammen und
jetzt gehen wir einmal unseren
schneebesen dran und dann wird das ganze
verrührt und so lange bis die sahne auch
steif ist
so und das war es auch schon wie creme
ist fertig jetzt nehmen wir uns ein
großes gefäß ich nehme meine schüssel
ihr könnt es aber auch in kleine gläser
füllen und dann schichten wir das ganze
bevor wir jetzt allerdings starten das
ganze zu schichten geht es noch mal ganz
kurz und die weintrauben papier die
kleinen die sind aus dem garten und die
hier sind aus dem supermarkt das sind
kernlosen trauben und wenn die so groß
sind dann finde ich es mal ein bisschen
schöner wenn man die halbiert oder sogar
viertel das ist einfach ein schöneres
mundgefühl wenn man das dann am ende ist
[Musik]
so ich verwende jetzt wie gesagt mein
amaranth müsli und falls er die cookies
verwendet dann gibt er sie nicht so aufs
dessert das ist viel zu groß gibt die
einfach in einen gefrierbeutel und haut
mit dem nudelholz drauf und dann habt
ihr so richtig grobe stücke und dann ist
es perfekt und das könnt ihr auch machen
habe ich auch ausprobiert ist auch super
lecker aber meine variante mit am rand
oder schoko müsli ist eben genau für
diejenigen die es nicht ganz so süß
mögen und jetzt schichten wir das aber
so lange rede kurzer sinn
[Musik]
und immer schön nach außen damit man das
auch von außen sieht was das geschichten
sind und dass sie dann auch optisch
schön aus wenn eben die weintrauben und
alles schön wenn man nach außen schiebt
die an den rand so
[Musik]
so dass große bisher ist jetzt fertig
und ich habe jetzt hier noch was übrig
und weil ich das gleich mitnehmen ich
bin gleich eingelassen grillen liegt der
haben sich hier noch so ein probe
päckchen probeweise ein bisschen was
machte aber auch mehrere auch für meine
eltern und das könnte eben auch frei
entscheiden ob ihr eine große schüssel
oder mehrere kleine desserts macht
[Musik]
ja das war schon so schnell ist unser
schicht ist er vorbereitet keine
unnötigen kühl zeiten hier muss man
nichts fest werden sie könnte sofort
servieren oder bis zum servieren im
kühlschrank aufbewahren
ich wünsche euch jetzt ein ganz viel
spaß im nachmachen die zutaten findet
ihr hier unten in der infobox ansonsten
freue ich mich wenn ihr den video einen
daumen nach oben gibt main kanal
kostenlos abonniert und im besten falle
sogar die glocke aktiviert dann verpasst
ja auch nichts mehr
und ich freue mich bis zum nächsten mal
auf die gis kitchen tschüss
[Musik]